the show garnered a huge following right
from the beginning because of your
chemistry with Nicole and the
relationship between those two
characters yeah and for the diversity of
the show's cast so um as you know
well-off English man from England going
to the States what have you learned
about the racial dynamics of Hollywood
and media um it's very interesting and
as you said having a very diverse cast
when we started it was not only Nicole
there was volando and John Cho and none
of the characters words would were
written with the exception of Ichabod
and Katrina because of their period
context none of the rest were written
with any ethnicity in mind it was purely
they want you to find the best actors
for each of the parts which i think is
such a beautiful perfect way of passing
anything but I think it's terrible when
you see this is this is the white actor
this is the black out this is the
Mexican actor it's not the right way to
go back I did notice instantly in in
America particularly when you have a
woman of color in the lead role it's not
just a woman of color in the lead role
it immediately means so much more than
that
across the whole of America it's someone
who there's a woman of color in a
position that not very long ago she
wouldn't have been and it comes to
symbolize so much more and so then when
something like this happens when they
kill off said character of course it's
going to it's going to mean an awful lot
more consequently it's something that I
don't think I haven't really noticed as
much over here strangely there are there
are still lots of discussions over here
about them about more opportunities for
for ethnic actors over here but but even
so the
that response to Abby's death over there
it was a huge thing I saw that there was
even and it got so far as there is an
article in The Washington Post about it
because everything else represented more
than just another character in the show
and I thought it was it wasn't an easy
decision for them to make I know that I
know the the writers you know pain they
like writing Abbie Mills and I like
acting with Nicole
but it was a decision that and I don't
know the the imaginations of of the
politics behind it
speaking of you know understand yeah
many ways the character was kind of a
safety net for Iggy Pop they'll shoot
Joe Carroll taking all the modern care
of all the warden conveniences and
translating everything to him yes how do
you think any camera will deal with you
not having that anymore well that'll be
the curious thing to find out I always
thought that I always thought of Ichabod
is the sidekick addley has to be the you
know she's that the one that with the
audience can relate to so when you're
entering into this this insane world of
Sleepy Hollow you go with Abby she's
been the guide and Ichabod is this
curious man in in the periphery which
also I loved playing that I think that
was you know it gave lots of
opportunities to explore the character I
never really funnily enough was
interested in Ichabod's backstory when
we started the first season I thought
this the less you know about him
probably the better and that's how he
can get away with all of his his work
the quirks quite and Abby is the
constant smooth guide through that that
then that changed a lot in in season two
when they then did start to explore
Ichabod's backstory
and so it'll be interesting to see where
they go without that crunch because I
still think that Abby was was grounding
that as well so no it'll be very curious
to see whether they decide to find
another way to ground Ichabod in in
reality or whether they think that he
has he's an inhabitant of the modern era
enough that he can do it on his own
I don't know what they're planning but I
don't envy them having to make that
decision
forming primary and lock Hospital for
the show I think that's good about that
yes a third company that I've been
involved with for a long time called
simple eight we were devising a show
that they put I couldn't be a part of it
sadly because of filming and a stage
adaptation moby-dick that was on last
year or the year before to the Arcola
and in the research and development
period we were exploring lots of sea
shanties and I became a little obsessed
with sea shanties I think they remarked
and so I had this huge the compendium of
sink shanties and and songs from that
era and that was a real favorite of mine
this brilliant beautiful haunting ballad
and you find out it's about a man who
caught syphilis of a frost and I thought
that would be a fun thing to have a club
sing at karaoke
I like it I like imagining him on the
journey over the three-month boat
journey over with lots of big big men
with rickets and scurvy singing the
songs about prostitutes and clapping
very proper
so can you remember the exact moment you
decided you wanted to act oh geez
I've been doing it a lot and when I was
a lad my I was encouraged to go into
amateur dramatics it
kept me off the streets I suppose and
then at one point during a performance
an actor came to watch and said
afterwards you know you can get paid for
this [ __ ] out but that'd be ridiculous
and it turns out he was he was telling
the truth and that's when I first
thought so I must have been about 14 it
was a production of cider with Rosie the
lorry lead Brook current member who
adapted it and I was playing the young
Lori Lee and my dad was a bit playing
the old Laurie move to amateur dramatics
it's like that and and yet then I
suddenly thought wow if I can do this
then amazing and I also watching and
Gene Wilder films when I was younger I
thought that's why I want to do for the
rest of my life I wanted to be Gene
Wilder and then I started watching Alec
Guinness I'm sorry I want to be Alec
Guinness and yeah probably that one okay
so thank you 14 so fans of Nicole we've
talked about this before put the cameras
on this time so I don't have to and
share it with the fans so fans of the it
could be relationship would lovely see
you and Nicole work together again oh
yeah the future so do you have any dream
projects that you would like to
collaborate with her on in the future or
perhaps theatre I'd love to do a play
when you come I'd really like that I'd
like to do clover lunch paper I'd like
to do a play with John Noble we were
discussing that yesterday and yeah of
course I think she's we found a real
rapport and found a very good steady
working relationship and if we can go
and explore something else with that
yeah I'm gladly doing because I had some
messages fans were wanting to know if
your friendship was fractured because of
I'll be getting killed off the show I
said a little dramatic by okay it's kind
of downtown behind my relationship with
Nicole has not changed
I didn't think it very concerned when
they can resting ISM is filming the new
series does it feel different from a new
series since departure um we start I
think we start in July the writers go
back in June and we start in July but
yes it will definitely feel different
the you know there were some episodes
where we weren't really together very
often and this even even without knowing
that next week I'll be filming with her
again it feels it feels differently set
feels different so yes it will be it
will be when did you know that I was
going to kill off wasn't very early on
er no no I found out an episode or two
before we started I think the decision
was made only an episode or two before
we shot up as I understand it it was an
idea that it was something not an idea
it was something that had been discussed
a little bit I don't think anyone really
thought it would happen and then the
decision was made you know very late on
very late on I don't know what episode
that would have been that we were
shooting something I'm looking at you
because you seem to be the expert on
everything get worried that's right he
was the one with the monster yeah is it
has it been disruptive to have to
calibrate the style of the show and like
your approach to playing the character
because of the you know the first season
was one type of way and then by the time
it was the third season it was basically
a procedural monster of the week
has it been like disruptive to your
equilibrium of playing the character oh
it's getting on my toes no I wouldn't
say it's been disruptive of course there
are you get really excited about other
avenues that don't excite you quite so
much but you know that's the same with
with every every time do you have a
preference for the more serialized
mythology of the show versus
monster-of-the-week um I'm a planetary
lines but I'm equally a fan of my bosses
I think they said they're clever and
know more than I do in terms of becoming
your characters do you just connect with
him by putting on the costume or do you
find something to over them become
actually enhancing sort of connection at
the very beginning when I read the pilot
the thing that really struck me was how
welding he was written on the page and
there are you know some scripts that you
read and you think okay well I need to
understand this about the character I
need to discover this about them and
that's how you work your way in and then
there are some that just leap out at you
instantly and when I first read the
pilot he lept out and I heard his voice
you know so it sounds very actor you
know wanky little me you kind of you
instantly know this is how I'd like to
to do it and then of course you get used
to the character after doing a tour for
three years it definitely helps putting
that on it definitely feels like a
change when you come in in it in a
t-shirt and jeans and then suddenly put
those on you immediately feel different
and it's a good way into the character I
remembered I'm reading an interview with
Ian McKellen when he was talking about
Gandalf and he said you know how do you
approach that it's the he'd he'd read
the books obviously and read the scripts
and it's such a a nuanced character
we're how do you begin and he was really
struggling with it and then we went for
a makeup test and they put on a false
nose like hard and then immediately they
put on the nose of their used and he
said everything fell into place and so
it varies you know sometimes you work
from the inside out and sometimes the
outside in luckily with this Len Wiseman
and I seem to have very very similar
ideas from the pilot so when he was
creating the look it it really didn't
differ from the idea that I had in my
head which is a relief so what was a
lighter character better adjust like the
modern time I mean that's always been
fun that's for me that's always been a
real highlight of the show which is why
also I think you know having a V as the
guide and Ichabod just skimming around
getting used for things that's that's
really fun
now that the series Ichabod has been
part of the modern world for such a long
time there are fewer things to surprise
surprise him it's a great shame that we
had that timely before the third season
because that's the time that April first
went into an aeroplane and I would love
to in fact that's an I had Alex Kurtzman
and one of the producers now had spoken
about that before would it be like pick
one in a plane and he said he'd probably
think going along the runway it was just
a really fast bus and then suddenly it
takes off and he freaks out and Jennie
will have to knock him out yeah do you
man that's my beer DVD extra DVD extra
very good maybe season 4 will be a
flashback to that missing time it won't
be perfect when you talk a bit about
your look so you said that you cut your
hair because you didn't know if the show
would be coming back and also did you
hear anything from the higher-ups about
because there's always this big thing
with Ichabod in his hair and like what
hair needs to look like oh yeah did you
get a stern talking-to no no they
haven't seen it yet
yeah I finished and I got a haircut and
god I hope it grows back before July
back into a week then well there could
be another time leap in another haircut
and another mode of transport for season
four sir particularly one character to
go down um well I know that weird it
seems to have been set up that ichabod
will go and join this new organization
set up by Washington I'd really like
particularly if it does take about to
Washington we are in in entering into
one of the weirdest times in modern
American history to have Donald Trump
running that's weird
that's just weird and I think if we are
going to be shooting boss in Washington
we shouldn't hide from the fact that
there has to be some dark underground
force that is making this surreal Tony
Danza guest star on the Trump having the
perfect from President Trump sorry
you'll be the monster of the week you'll
be the monster of four years sorry
you mentioned Trump and instantly the
mood of a rope chain it's so funny
because he just kind of looked like Biff
Biff yeah yeah Venice Tower in his big
Tower
I thought the character was really
inspired from Trump he's not trans that
is wonderful
wardrobe did they tell you anything
about what you're meant to be married
because that's like how long is he going
to hold onto the clothes I hope I hope
that the clothes doesn't change only
it's nice to have it's kind of I've
always thought of it as a security
blanket for him it's the one it's the
last thing especially now everyone he
has ever known is dead it's the one
thing he has from me at the moment when
he wanted to change good one an episode
there was that moment and he didn't like
it I won't wear skinny jeans yeah and
I'd Len Wiseman actually always said
that we can have variations on it much
like you know superheroes have
variations on on their theme but no it's
it Len always wanted you know an iconic
look where you can see a silhouette of
it and you'll recognize it is so I'm
hoping I'm not after all this time what
take about three years now what would
you advise him you would have yeah if
you were the spices yeah he's very
strange it's hard for me to be frowning
for such a long time and go on holiday
I'd like to he should go on holiday tit
somewhere like the Maldives and we'll go
and film there for a couple of months
the same costume thing right you try to
get him jeans off you know tight shorts
or tight shorts or speedos yeah thank
you thank you so much thank you
you